the u.s president says the august 31st
deadline still stands
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were trans were transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
military aircraft continue to take off
from kabul airport it's a 24-hour
operation
on board some of the tens of thousands
of people who have been evacuated since
the taliban seized power on august the
15th
but it's estimated tens of thousands
more are desperate to leave
despite pressure from governments around
the world and before the u.s president
made his statement the taliban
reiterated there would be no extension
of the august 31st deadline for the
remaining nato soldiers in afghanistan
to get out
we will not allow an extension beyond
august 31st so the us should remove and
evacuate all personnel by the set
deadline
mujahid said the taliban is stopping
afghans from going to the airport
the islamic emirate is trying to
encourage people to go home but the
americans are inviting people to go to
the airport their adverse policy of
continuing to board people on planes the
airport access route has been closed to
avoid stampedes
the un's top human rights official told
an emergency session of the un human
rights council she has received credible
reports of the taliban committing
serious violations including summary
executions of civilians and restrictions
on women a fundamental red line will be
the taliban's treatment of women and
girls and respect for their rights to
liberty freedom of movement education
self-expression and employment guided by
international human rights norms in
particular ensuring access to quality
secondary education for girls will be an
essential indicators of commitment to
human rights
the taliban spokesman said women should
for the time being stay at home because
taliban fighters were not yet trained on
how to behave
we need to have a procedure and a plan
in place security force is not
operational they are not trained to deal
with women that's why we're stopping
women from going to work we ask women to
stay home and their salaries will be
resuming
come back to work when we have a system
in place
with no extension of the august 31st
deadline there are mounting concerns for
tens of thousands of afghans that want
to leave this country
the taliban says they have nothing to
fear and that there will be no reprisals
against people who have worked with nato
foreign organizations or the media in
the past
but trusting the taliban on the basis of
their words alone is something that many
afghans and the international community
find very difficult to do
charles stratford al jazeera kabul